eric antoine c'est mon héritage oui ça
c'est que tu voulais nous servent le
tour ce tour de magie
c'est vraiment je vous le dis c'est un
tour de magie je vous jure qu'il n'a
jamais réalisé
ils vont lévitation et je vous le dis
juste après les chéris maintenant lui
qu'il y aura du chocolat pour tout le
monde parce que c'est pâques et je
donnerai le nom de la femelle du lévrier
à doc gynéco pour vous dire qu'il ya
d'autres petits trucs à faire avant de
voir hommes font mais c'est rien ça va
très rapide
eric je te laisse faire très bien alors
j'aurai juste besoin de quelqu'un pour
m'aider une assistante prend alors je
prends la plus grande je prends
géraldine parce que c'est celle qui est
la mieux foutu cérébralement on va oui
on a monté sur scène ça te plaît ne
voulait surtout pas je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
messieurs eric eric mosseri pour eric tu
vas nous faire un tour de magie
oui donc et tu vas faire léviter je vais
faire léviter les chroniqueurs qui ont
peu de chances de revenir l'année
prochaine dit hantée pmp et certains
d'entre vous vont disparaître
complètement
ce soir il a appuyé sur un bouton à la
fin c'est ça c'est ça c'est géraldine
qui va appuyer sur un bouton pour ce
responsable à faire quelque chose des
chroniques et surtout s'il vous plaît
vous nous approchons vous ne bougez pas
je vais vous demander de fermer les yeux
tous de fermer les yeux mettez les mains
devant les yeux ou non pas les manants
ferme et juste fermer les yeux
non tu es condamné vous la main c'est
mieux et donner la raison comme ça vous
voudrez l'énergie entre vous voilà voilà
fait bouffer voit la super console
devrait fermer les yeux s'il vous plaît
aussi ma chérie on a la pression était
les yeux fermés mais les yeux quand même
moi j'aurais reçu beaucoup moins du tour
mais chez lui
[Musique]
ils ont les yeux fermés public ils ont
les yeux fermés ou pas match ça peut
faire mal faire mais j'ai vraiment aimé
mais non mais non c'est rien du tout non
plus qui vaut cher
pas du tout vous allez produire a dit
bah ouais on est tous les wc relève ton
booty gérant du oui mais oui
géraldine c'est à vous de jouer vous
allez choisir ses deux buzzer il y en a
combien qui vont aller vite et il y en a
au moins deux qui vont éviter deux cas
les qualités vous versiez au plaisir
c'est non mais mettez vous bien aller ça
suffit merci alors vous avez deux heures
scheer géraldine devant vous avez choix
donc entre le buzzer de gauche le buzzer
de droite vous choisissez celui que vous
voulez pas besoin de donner aux besoins
des droites à ce n'est pas n'appuyez pas
sur ce buzz et surtout pas celui là
puisque celui là si c'est celui le plus
dangereux ce nom c'est celui qui
déclenche en fait ce qui reste cette
année
d'accord donc surtout pas celui là c'est
sûr celui voilà au choix au hasard entre
le buzzer de droite au choix au hasard
entre meiser des sciences donnés sous la
main fermez fermez les yeux les amis
mais eric antoine
kelly kelly kelly kelly arrêté de
toucher les trucs tout ça allez c'est
bon
3 a fait pas mal ça fait pas mal mais
c'est vous allez juste l'éviter 3-1 pas
sur nous si si c'est bon je suis beau
matin oui celui droite
ok ou peut-être que c'est celui de
touche j'ai lancé sur la droite je suis
pro calais on y va fermez vos yeux 2,3 à
daisy
[Musique]
les
à
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai jamais parlé de ces plans se
calme c'est hradecka billet sur la base
des boutons les chéris je vous avais
promis de chocolat pour tout le monde
c'était pas comme ça que je voulais
qu'ils viennent là